normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
the Chicago Tribune construction on
Brighton Park migrant Camp to begin with
State involvement this week despite
aldermanic opposition can I just point
out really quickly that beautiful word
Alder manic man I have not made a movie
about this just I want to be clear about
the Alder manics Al Alder men are the
are like the mayors of a neighborhood so
I love the Alder manic opposition it's a
great word but uh here's what's
happening the people of Chicago are
Furious they do not want illegal
immigrants in their City same is true
for New York Democrats are suffering
because of this but it doesn't matter
why several reasons there's one base
reason and the simple reason is there
are men who are willing to take blood
Money stripped from your pockets and
your bank accounts to build facilities
for non-citizens and they don't care
they don't care about your community
they don't care about you they don't
care about what happens to the city when
the government comes to these men in
these construction vehicles and says
here's the project they say okay I'll
take money no matter where it comes from
so the people of Chicago in opposition
to this are having their tax dollars
taken and these men are willing to
accept it that's the first problem
second problem is politically they do
not care what the people of the city
actually want they will build facilities
for non-citizens and this is going to be
I think politically apocalyptic for
Democrats because now we're seeing
Donald Trump is improving among Black
and Hispanic voters and I think this is
partly due to you get these videos out
of Chicago where it's black community
members screaming get these illegal
immigrants out of our neighborhoods they
don't care but but let me just stress
also the sheer shock when I saw a video
on Twitter X where they're like we are
building a camp on the south side of
Chicago for illegal immigrants we're not
talking like a small Park we're talking
a massive multi-acre facility they're
talking brick and mortar structures
yeah what do they mean by Camp they just
mean a building no they're building
multiple structures yeah well this is
like when you hear refugee camp inside
the Gaza Strip and then it turns out
it's a city with skyscrapers right
interesting word C Camp is a yeah well
one of them is a tent city so I guess
you can call but when you have multiple
Acres I don't know if if it has PL if it
has Plumbing though it's a at a minimum
it's a migrant clamp well we there was a
thing in New York just recently where
they put up a whole bunch of dormitories
at Floyd Bennett Field which is a you
know an old Airfield and uh migrants
were warning each other not to go there
they were like oh no it's not acceptable
and one woman said we did not go because
we already know the situation over there
we saw people returned with children
they say it's not suitable there there
is nothing there not even a
television no TV no TV oh my goodness
that's a violation I think it's a human
rights violation human un Charter Violet
we got to what's going on no TVs we
should protest I have to say I have
loved seeing you know black people in
Chicago and New York just be like no
we're not doing this it makes me think
that maybe we can REM yeah Eric Adams
has been really working on this and he
has been stymied at every step of the
way and now they're attacking him now
they're attacking him they're they're
destroying the schools you know that
were already faltering um but I have
loved seeing black Americans stand up
and be like no we don't want this it
makes me think that perhaps all of us
Americans or as original Americans can
get together and be like we're Americans
we love our country we don't want it to
be over run race is not the thing that
should divide us here you know it should
be the Border absolutely culture is real
and the great lie of the 20th century is
that culture is not real that all
cultures are equal that you can
relativism that you can yeah you can
basically Shuffle the deck of all humans
across the entire globe and still wind
up with the exact same soup and you
can't you know France is a place for
French people and England is a place for
the English and America is a place for
Americans and you could say well there's
no such thing as Americans and that's
true but there's no such thing as
English either like at a certain point
cultures
come and they go and America yes is a
nation that was founded largely by
immigrants but those immigrants did come
together and create a culture I'm not
anti-immigration but I'm anti any kind
of immigration that radically and
rapidly changes the makeup of the
culture of a country because you can't
have a nation if you don't have culture
you have to have common culture well
this this is an important uh Point uh
the Constitution the Bill of Rights are
what 1789 we had free speech yeah they'd
still arrest you for Oben laws if you
spoke in certain ways like George Carin
famously even in in the 7s you get
arrested for it it is the culture that
we have today this is why I say we're
winning a lot of people don't want to
accept it but you can look at the
tangible realities of the budlight
boycott I want to say right now I'm a
huge fan of budlight and a big supporter
of theirs after they sponsored UFC we
were very critical of them but then
seeing what Sean Strickland said did you
see this one no so so Bud Light SP but
uh but let me just wrap that point up
we're winning by the way and this is the
point we winning Sean Strickland said he
was so happy that budlight sponsored UFC
and we're like no oh come on budlight
they're crooked and then he's like now
they're putting money behind every word
I say and I went oh okay I agree I agree
there's no backing down for Bud Light
now MMA fighters are notoriously based
and he said some stuff that I can't say
on YouTube and the UFC paid for it I'm
sorry sorry Bud Light paid for it so now
I'm like okay I'll take it there you go
he's fixing the brand by going a little
far in the other direction well you've
seen their advertising it's sort of like
it's like ' 80s spectacular advertising
all of a sudden I do make a Bud Light
joke in lady Ballers and maybe I should
reevaluate it although it's too late now
well but we were wondering when's
Jeremy's beer I mean you've got
everything else yeah I will uh here's
some breaking news oh for our timcast
fans there will not be a Jeremy's beer
when you when you watch lady Ballers
this weekend you will notice that there
are cans all throughout the movie that
say Jeremy's pner on them they're very
welld designed and that's because I
thought that by the time the movie came
out I would release my
pser but it turns out canned beverages
are very difficult and alcohol is even
more difficult still and I've I've made
the decision that and I don't drink so
somehow in this combination of of
challenges I thought maybe just let that
one slide but as what I want what I
wanted to say about winning is when you
look at freedom of speech despite the
government manipulations and collusion
with big Tech we are I believe we are
winning we're winning culturally we're
not winning in Po in the realm of policy
yet which matters right but I agree that
there's I agree that there's a shift
culturally in our favor right we've
begun forwarding the line yes as the way
I would describe it we may not have the
whole battlefield but also the Second
Amendment i i i i there I I do not
believe there is we have the whole
Battlefield I mean or I should say we
have we have more than 26 State States
uh constitutional carry or permitless
concealed car I think Florida and so
that is the majority of the battlefield
in terms of Statewide now they're trying
still to ban things but they're losing
there was a poll NBC News the poll that
showed young voters are leaning Trump by
like two uh it's a four-point margin
also show that the majority of people
whether you're democrat or republican
have guns in their household yeah so I
think we're winning constitutionally now
I'd love to see uh uh there there's a
lot of stuff going to the Supreme Court
let's see you know what we get through
there's um I I don't know if I should
say too much but one of our guests was
talking about another case on uh uh the
NFA which is being is going is going to
be uh challenged all the way to the
Supreme Court we'll see how it plays out
but I think I think we are winning so
I'm having a good time there's bad stuff
going on we call the bad stuff all the
time y but uh the night is always
darkest before the dawn however there is
a light at the end of the tunnel I'm
seeing a lot of people on both sides
understand that the border is a mess you
know like when I saw Eric Adams talking
about I was completely shocked I've been
to the Border a few times reporting on
it this year it is a complete tragedy
completely open the amount of fentanyl
coming through is is absurd and and
undocumented people who just get sent
wherever they want to go you it's like
soft TSA down there I mean it's so bad I
am livid at the story of the
construction happening in Chicago and ie
all of my anger is at the workingclass
construction guys 100% did you see um
they they should have said I ain't
touching that money instead they were
just like yeah I'll take money to
disrupt and destroy this community it's
it's it's disgusting there should be a
concept of a country over company the
founding fathers were wealthy men they
were very wealthy and they had every
reason to say to anyone with patriotic
sentiments shut your mouths you're going
to spoil my fun I've got I've got land
I've got buildings I've got properties
I've got companies and I got a family to
protect I ain't signing that Declaration
of Independence they did the opposite
they said the king will kill me he will
take my family he will beat my children
he will steal from me and I will be left
destitute but it must be done it's not
rare in these big cities for these
companies to have the unions who are
with the government tight tight you know
so that's why maybe this is not as
surprising yeah that's right did you see
the The Washington Post came out in
favor of border control they said in a
no wow yeah in an editorial board they
said um Democrats might Flinch at the
proposition but the Republican idea that
it should be tougher for Asylum Seekers
to enter the United States makes some
sense wow just some yeah he said they
said um hundreds of thousands of people
who reach the southern border every year
hope to leave a dismal existence behind
but most are not fleeing persecution in
fear for life or limb they seek Asylum
because the US Asylum system is the only
door available to knock
on that's in the Washington Post the the
border patrol that I talk to down there
all all different types of people are
like there's so many just men about our
age coming over they don't know where
they're from they're not like from not
all from Mexico they're from China from
Africa they're all from all various
places UK and and they do get a lot of
people who are repeat offenders as in
they've come been kicked out and they
come back uh but they just got through
there's there's so many places where
there's a hole in the wall or or uh you
know these tribes have their land on the
border and they don't have a wall
because it's s Sovereign land so you
just walk to the wall and be like skir
right around and you're in and that's it
uh so it's great to see that I wonder
what they how they Define border policy
but start in one of these stories uh it
was a story from ABC7 they interviewed a
Honduras
migrant who said I'm living worse than I
lived in Honduras it's very cold I want
to go
home were saying that in Chicago this is
typical someone some group is lying to
these people and telling them to come
and they arrive in freezing cities with
no resources and they're like I don't
understand they're like the streets are
paved with gold they get to San
Francisco and it's paved with poop well
I mean literal poop literally these
people are told there are jobs and
they're they're they're like oh the
United States has opened the Border
they're saying come there's jobs for you
and they go oh okay they hop on on these
trains They Ride thousands of miles and
they show up and they're like this is
not correct and the funny thing is even
now Democrats are are outraged over this
but you have Progressive leftists that
are still and the woke they're they're
still very much in that I mean AOC is
pretty mum on this one right she's the
Trump concentration Camp's person she
she will she will burn her political
base if she comes out and says no this
is a good thing now hold on she did
remember when initially when she said
we're going to get work permits for them
housing for them and people were
screaming at her so I think she Hotel in
New York the Democrats are in trouble
even the progressive ones she's such an
opportunist I could see her down the
road probably soon from now look what
you said about Hamas yeah Israel
Palestine did you she this is this is
someone who has a roots in in in
Progressive leftism before she's in
office the uh uh the activists were
operating under the assumption that she
was Pro Palestine her position now is we
need surgical strikes to assassinate
Hamas and I'm like
someone knows who her constituents do
not like Hamas but her woke Progressive
fan base Doh so she she chooses the
political mainstream which is the only
path towards I mean look let's be let's
be real she represents the Bronx that's
not really a it's not that Progressive
it's mostly poor and I think that the
let's be honest there's a 40% chance
she's president you think so think oh
yeah a if the culture doesn't shift away
from that that's right it's possible
there there's a real path for AOC to be
president we like to make fun of her
because well for all the reasons there's
so many re that's why she says that are
surprising to us sometimes cuz she sees
it it's all politics she doesn't have
any moral center it's whatever's going
to get her to the White House but I I
think you're right 40% might be the
right number uh not greater than chance
but significant I I don't know that
right now she has the gravitas but she
certainly could Oh no you're saying down
the line yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
going to be not 2024 yeah but that's
what I mean I see her running for sure
she she has a like 40% seems like the
correct number there there there is a
possibility eight or 10 years she has
developed that that personal maybe Nikki
Haley will pick her as vice president oh
my
goodness perhaps well the rumor is she
wants to run for I don't know if this is
true she wants to be senator in New York
or something I think that is true I
think she wants to do that who would she
replace Schumer would she go after
Schumer SE yeah apparently that's it
that's the one that's open to her it'll
it'll probably happen there so crazy up
there I mean we got we felt sort of good
for getting Cuomo out I mean not cuz he
was me too I didn't think he deserved
that I thought he should have been for
mass murder yeah I mean I remember when
he released the video of him kissing
everybody he's like I I do this to
everybody and like so the response was
you admit to doing it more than we
thought right it I mean the thing is
that's how you push people out of that's
how you push people out of office in New
York you accuse them of random sexual
harassment crap from years ago and then
take their job and put in someone way
worse is a disaster yeah Eric Adams with
his like they demanding 5 million from
him what did he even do nobody even
knows it was from like 1993 hok's hok's
really really bad I mean she was talking
about having disciples for the for the
shot back in the day uh now her whole
thing of like uh she's in it with
Laticia James the hate speech thing
they're they're going to monitor
people's social media yeah it's it's
nuts but that's also I love New York
it's my home state and it's not all that
bad thanks for watching this clip from
the Tim IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net